manufacturers managers farmers or
entrepreneurs you've come up with this
great invention
now you produce it and you are exporting
it to several WTO countries outside the
EU to Asia to America to Africa new
orders come from all over the world but
you've heard about new legislation under
preparation in one of your export
countries what can you do the best
option is first to do a search of the EU
TVT database it will tell you about
technical regulations planned in each
WTO country and let you identifies those
that could hamper the export of your
products abroad if you're forewarned you
have an opportunity to take action
and that's where we come in we will
investigate your concern and contact the
WTO member and question if needed
in short you can relax and get on with
your job while we draw up the EU
comments and send them to the WTO member
in question in the best case scenario we
will be able to prevent the provisions
concern from being adopted or to
postpone their entry into force in any
place information about the plan new
rules will be available on the EU TBT
database whatever happens you will have
some time to make adjustments or sell
off your stock isn't this wonderful
TBT agreement expand your trading in the
global market